STANDINGS.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE GAME STAM.
PICKED UP BY IT
DIFFICULT.
GREAT GLOVE SAVE RIGHT THERE.
YOU CAN SEE STAMKOS MAKING A
PASS O GAMES, A
1-0 WIN FOR THT, GOOD
POSITIONS BY SOROKIN WHO, AS YOU
CAN SEE, GETS ON THEHELL FOR LE.
LEE FROM THE LITTLE BACK AROUNER
THE GLASS. GOING
TO THE STICK SIDE, TUCKS IT BACK
IN, GOESY BROCK NELSON.
POINT CARRIES IT OVER THE LINE.
THIS IS  SHOOTING IT LOW ALONG
THE ICE?
>>T DIFFICULT
BECAUSE, YOU'RE RIGHT,AY FOR TH.
THEY'RE  THERE SAYS IT
WAS DEFLECTED.
NO PENALTYF ROOM.
FEW TIMES.
THAT'S WHY RYAN IS OUT OF THE
LINEUP.
>> Brendan: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
UPPE AND KILLORN THE STICK
LATE ON IT.
BARZAL TO THENOUGH ON IT T 3 ON.
HEDMAN DOES HE GO OVER - INSIDE
>> HE MISSES IT THERE WHEN HE
TRIES TO CHIP IT TH IS THE KEY.
THE GAMEHE GOT TURNED BACK BECA.
WHAT A STOP THAT WAS BY  THERE,
TO.
PERRY BEHINDN THE NATIONAL OFF .
HE SEL